الصفوف الذكيه هو احد ما وصل اليه العلماء
في مجال التعليم مع انتشار التكنولوجيا
بشكل كبير بين الطلاب طبعا اكاديميه
الاعداد للجامعه في بروكلين بالولايات
المتحده كشفت النقاب عن صاله ذكيه مخصصه
للقراءه والكتابه اصاله تضم في مساحتها
مكتبه صغيره ومقاعد مريحه للقراءه واماكن
للتركيز العالي وجهاز لوحي كبير ومصر كذلك
فان الغرفه الدراسيه تحتوي على اجهزه
استشعار ايضا تحسب عدد مرات حديث الطلاب
مع الحفاظ على خصوصيه الاحاديث
مراقبين مراقبين في كل المجالات
يعني ما ادري اتوقع انه هذه
الاجواء بحاجه الى ان تكون في كل مكان ما
ادري بعض الناس لديها طقوس حينما تقرا
القهوه ولا ولا لا
يدرس اي شيء او او يقرا او كذا
بقدر اقرا هو كان في يعني
حرب فوق راسي اذا قررتني اركز بركز على
طارق ايضا مدن الملح انا واحد من الناس
الى الان لا استطيع القراءه من الايباد او
الاجهزه اللوحيه لازم هي النسخه الورقيه
قديمه كما يقال
برامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات